Hey, everybody.
Hey.
Oh, my goodness.
Are we in a good mood today?
We are.
I mean...
You were shut out of a cannon.
I was shot out of a cannon.
I'm all fired up.
We get to do some potting today.
Yeah.
And I'm so excited you two are here for this.
You're going to have such a hoot.
What we do is that little foam thing in front of your mouth, you just speak into that.
We're going to have somebody of interest coming on soon.
You're going to be able to be a hoot.
able to ask any questions
that you might have.
And they should respond in a somewhat
informative way. Nobody's left. Nobody's left.
Nobody's going to listen now.
You think they've turned the dial?
Well, then let's hurry up and get the guest out here.
Come on. Welcome to Smartless.
What is that from?
Hi.
That's like a...
I'll do smart list.
Oh, my.
Jesus.
Isn't that a...
Isn't that...
Don't they use that in...
Sports things?
Yeah.
Hey, Sean.
Are you doing an ad for All-American guy?
You just took a big gulp of milk, and now you took a bite of an apple.
Yeah, I just got back.
What happened?
You ran out of Pop-Tarts?
Oh, my God.
Dude, hit the horn again.
There you go.
Hey, did Archie give you that app or something?
Is that next to the fart one?
No, man.
I've had it for a long time, embarrassing.
enough. Did I tell you, somebody
gave me a box of pop tarts outside the
stage door? Did they
really? Yeah. It was the greatest
gift. What a crowd.
There was a bow around it.
And I was like, that was the nicest gift ever.
Did security tackle them?
No. Remember when we went on tour
and that somebody handed me a sandwich
and I ate it? And Jason
was like, I remember that we got in the car. You're like,
Why would you ever eat a sandwich from somebody off the street?
I'm like, because I was hungry.
You're trying to get me to remember the time that you ate a sandwich?
No.
No?
I just kind of heighten it.
If it's not, if it's dragged across the finish line.
He needs a little punch.
No, I know.
By the way, it should be noted.
I text it, J.B.
I'm going to embarrass him.
The boys and I, Artape and I watched that first episode of DTS, St. Louis.
He's so good.
Wait.
Listen,
Jason, you're so good at playing a simp.
Go ahead, Sean.
I mean, I just, I almost, Jay,
it's like one of those incredible, powerful performances
that I felt like when I saw Willie do his movie too
where I'm looking at you right now,
I've known you for 75,000 years,
and I don't know who you are.
Like, it was so unbelievably a different person
that I did not believe I was watching you.
Johnny finished it last night.
I finished the whole series.
Yeah, last night.
How do you have all?
I gave them mine.
We finished the first episode,
and I turned to the boys,
and I literally looked at my go,
how many episodes away are we from Jason getting pegged?
Jay, I mean, that's pretty close.
I could go on and on.
I know.
It's so good.
I was in tears at the end because I was so proud of my friend Jason.
It's really good.
Everybody's great.
Linda Cardellini is amazing.
David Harbor really great.
David Harbor is great.
I'm not comparing anybody, but Jason, you are so good in this part, honestly.
I really appreciate you.
And it's so, I mean, were you.
And it's not surprising.
It should be noted, too, because, you know, when people go, you were really good.
Always hurts.
But I texted Jason yesterday last night about, like, what a huge.
swing it was to
to do this i mean will
wait until you see
i don't say it in another word i don't know
a new one came out last night and i couldn't watch last night
so right i mean it just this guy
Steve conrad this writer-director
we'll leave the subject sorry listener
but this guy Steve connor this writer-director
he's just so
creative and like daring and
yeah but like without being obnoxiously like
oh look how
alvanguard and and you know
it's just
Like, it's so...
It serves the characters
It's so relatable
that it makes it absolutely
almost impossible to watch
because it's so cringy and real and awkward.
And so much so, I woke up today
I started doing just regular whatever tasks
thinking about DTF St. Louis
and these characters and I'm like...
Were you sitting on Scotty's face?
Those are his regular tasks.
Way to you...
Check.
Wait a minute.
The viewers will understand what we're talking about.
Yeah, that's a little precursor what happens.
But anyways, incredible.
You're very nice.
Thank you, men.
Willie, it's nice to have you back in the States.
You made it.
Was there any issues at the border, or was it pretty smooth?
Still good.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I'm in good standing.
Your bronze are still, you haven't run out of that.
No, no.
It's a little streaky.
Fresh toothed.
I can't get behind.
I can't see.
And my feet, obviously, my feet are always a mess when I get sprayed as much.
I used to go to that thing all the time.
Did you used to go to those things?
Remember that?
In the boxes?
I've never done it.
No, I've literally never done it.
Do you remember the episode of Rested Development when David Cross had to blow himself or blew it?
He says, I just blew myself.
He had to put on his own blue man makeup.
Yes.
I just read this morning, David's got a brand new comedy special.
His ninth one is self-releasing on his website and on YouTube.
I forget the date, but it's probably on now.
Love David Cross. Go see it.
Oh, that's right.
Click it.
Click it and forget it.
I love D.C.
Wait, one time really quick.
I went into this.
DC, remember he used to start?
Just in the, especially first year, we'd do something, and David go like, that's so late.
Like, we discussed, Jason and I would describe something we'd do to go, that's pretty lame.
And we'd go, oh, sorry, street cred.
We started calling him street cred, which he actually ended up liking.
It made him laugh.
Hey, street head coming up.
Yeah.
Anyway.
God, I love him.
Shall we?
Yeah, I thought you were going to say something, Shawnee.
No, that subject went too far away.
It's about this tanning thing.
Bring it back.
Because I used to, I was so white when I would have to have an event to go to or something,
my makeup lady from Will & Grace, she would come over on cake on tanning stuff on my face.
Was it Patty?
Yeah, Patty Bunch, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's the best.
And she forgot to do my hands.
Oh, boy.
And I won a SAG Award.
And so, you know, you do the line.
the photos.
I'm holding up the sagg awards
and my hands are as white
as snow and my face
is as orange as the sun.
That's up there with
sometimes in a particularly
unemployed summer I will play a bunch of golf
and the tan difference
I'll see it now.
Between a glove hand
and the non-glove hand
is very ugly.
All right, great.
Super hashtag-relations.
Yeah, first world problem was extreme. We just lost 50,000 listeners.
Today, we have one of my favorite actors. She always has been. I've had the great fortune
of working with her a couple of times, and it is as good in person as it is on film. She is not only
an actor, but also a producer and a writer, but not just any writer. This is a playwright.
And recently a columnist, which we will talk about. It's very exciting. After more than 25 years of doing
great work, it's even greater right now.
She's got a new season of her hit show
on Apple starting this spring. She's got a
brand new film being released, has a
very fancy publication of
her essay dropping, and
has successfully gotten
through yet another year of marriage
to a real ding-dong.
She's a unicorn, folks, and
here she is. Please welcome my long-time, nearest and
dearest friend, Ms. Amanda Pete.
Get out here.
Boy, do we have
stuff to talk about?
Hi, Shawnee.
Hi, honey, how are you?
I'm okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Hi, Amanda.
You guys, I did almost do like 25 spit dates.
And I wasn't sure if I was supposed to be.
She is prone to a spit tape.
Look at you with a microphone.
Look at you.
Oh, should I put that down?
No, no, no.
Sean has his?
Oh, you guys all have yours.
We're not doing video.
This isn't video?
That's the one we sent you, isn't it?
I've just never seen you in this environment.
So it's all new to me.
It's so great to see you.
I'm so excited.
She said me a text.
She said, can I look like a slob?
I go, yeah, I'm on PJs.
I'm always in my PJs.
You don't think you're being recorded is your voice.
He only travels into PJs.
Wow, you are really tan, Will.
I know, I know.
I get that a lot.
As you know.
Smoking and sun.
Not good.
I know.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
Is it still happening, Will?
We're still chipping?
It's still really annoying that you're so.
so good with addictions now, I guess.
You've got it all handled.
You can just chip away at the cigarettes and it doesn't take over?
Yeah, I mean, I'm pretty good.
I go through phases.
I can't do a little of anything.
I know.
Me neither.
I generally can't either.
Amanda, how are you with sugar?
I'm really bad with sugar.
I mean, it's not great.
Yeah, what's the one thing?
I need it out.
If you could go to an addict's
what circle meeting whatever it's called what would it what would it what would it be for Amanda oh
what's what's the thing you want to kick I can't say it I think oh you can't really I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding we talk about porn here all the time that is something I don't have a problem
yeah no what is it I'm addicted to exercise really no for real kidding oh fucking are you
kidding right right do you know me at all Sean it would be sugar for you oh my
my God, I can't, I can't not go a day without eating tons of sugar.
Have you tried to just get it out of the house?
Like, have you tried the thing where it's like proximity?
Well, and then like, I eat an apple.
Like, okay, well, that has sugar, but the good kind.
But then I'll have a snickers right after this.
Just a full-grown snickers.
I haven't had a snickers since Halloween when I was 14.
But you know what?
I texted these guys the other night.
I came home after doing two shows.
And I had a plate of spaghetti and a donut.
on the same plate.
On the same plate.
Don't you think you're burning enough adrenaline?
That's what I'm saying.
Two shows.
Like it just probably just...
It's a one-man show, too.
That's what I'm saying.
But he sent the photo of the pasta of the spaghetti bolognese
and then a chocolate donut with a bite out of it.
So then I FaceTimed him just because I wanted kind of verification
because I thought that he'd set it for the photo for effect.
And sure enough, donut is on the plate.
He's eating them both simultaneously.
Yeah.
I really was.
And a glass of milk.
I often think how when, you know, I have an 11-year-old,
I often think of how one of the great, great pleasures of being an adult,
a grown-up, is that you can eat your dessert before your meal.
Sure.
Yeah.
There's no rules.
Well, actually, I said, if you remember, I said to you,
were you at an 11-year-old's birthday party?
Yeah.
And I said I stopped by on the way home from one.
Amanda Pete.
Southie.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
Amanda, you worked with Amanda.
Amanda and I worked together first.
Almost 30 years ago,
we did a film called, I know, sorry.
Sorry to say that number right now.
Jesus.
I don't feel good about it either.
Do you guys both still have your Boston?
Sad cards?
Bassin accents.
They almost took our sad cards away.
They came on set.
What did you work on together?
Southie.
It was called Southie.
It was a film about South Boston.
Oh, I didn't know that.
How are you? Good to see you? Good, good for you, Amanda.
You're doing good, huh?
Wait, Amanda, did you do the accent, too?
Do you still have it? I think I might have.
Do it just a little bit.
I can't even fucking remember.
Honestly, I can't even fucking remember because I was in fucking dead.
They're going to kick me out of the condo.
They're going to kick me out of the condo soon.
That was terrible. Wow.
No, that was good.
Condo is good, though. Condo.
Still rolling.
Wow.
Real.
Root.
Rude.
Wait, was Donnie Wahlberg the star of that film?
So Donnie Wahlberg was a star.
Donnie Wahlberg, Rose McGowan, you, me,
and directed by John Shea.
Anne Mira.
Who, by the way, Sean, I was saying,
I was about to do a play after Southie,
and I was telling her about how I have terrible stage fright,
and I was trying to just chat with her about it,
and she had, you know, she was a chain smoker,
and she just said,
As soon as you want to be good, you're dead.
Wow.
Wow, that's a good quote.
Isn't that deep?
Yeah, she was cool.
She was no nonsense.
She was cool.
That's kind of cool.
As soon as you want to be good.
Yeah.
Wait, wait, tell me about the stage fright.
I guess I have that.
I guess we all have that a bit.
Yeah, I figure out how to not flip out at an early stage.
Just drink.
Right before you get on.
Is it, well, yeah.
You know what I do?
My little sort of trick I've always done for a long time,
especially when you're going to do something kind of live or whatever,
and you're like, I got to get out there, and I just go,
I am where I am, and literally use it, this is energy, okay.
And I just, so don't try to get over it,
do it.
That's incredibly annoying.
Just flip it, just flip it.
Flip it and forget it.
Yeah, I don't have those kinds of nerves, dude.
Honestly, that's a good impression of me.
Now, has it always been like that?
Here we go.
Let's go back to the beginning, Amanda.
Do you have to?
A kid.
Yes.
When you were a kid, was it always going to be this?
Like, did you have a plan for this?
Or did you just kind of wing it and, like, the entertainment world kind of came your way?
Or was it like, no, let's set the oars in this direction and start rowing?
I think both parents.
That's good.
That's enough.
Thank you.
And we'll go to our first break.
No, both parents are off crowd.
Both parents were as far from the entertainment business as you could possibly be.
What kind of?
Corporate lawyer.
Yale undergrad, Harvard Law School.
My mom was a social worker, psychotherapist.
Wow.
And I feel like they saw acting.
in the beginning, similarly to just,
oh, so you want to start modeling.
You want to join the circus.
You want to be a hooker.
Right.
Yeah.
Wow.
Sex worker.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sex worker.
Did you work to sort of convince him
that that wasn't the way you were seeing it
and what your intentions were?
Or did you just kind of like hide your pursuit?
Yes, I think I was constantly trying to make it appear
less frivolous.
But interestingly,
apropos of what we were just saying,
I think because I had terrible stage fright,
it was much easier for me to book things like
a chapstick commercial or days of our lives.
Like as soon as I was lucky enough
to get an audition for something like a Clifford Odette's play
or something like that, I was like this.
Just shaking.
And I couldn't do what I was doing in class
you know in real life so so literally stage was was like that that was your kryptonite but being in front
of camera was was less no sorry i didn't explain that right so anything highbrow i was like terrified
oh got so and then anything that was like considered more lowbrow right you kill i could
kill it and so then i was undoing what i wanted to portray to my parents
Yeah.
Because I'd be like, well, I'm on a Skittles commercial and they'd be like, I arrest my case.
Right, right, right.
Well, how about that?
That's actually, that's a good strategy to overcome, you know, like don't overvalue
something.
Maybe like find something about whatever you're going to be doing that's giving you
the nerves that sort of undercuts it.
Well, yeah, I mean, not to get too, like, deep about it, but both my kids were, you know,
given offers to go.
go play and then you know you have three oh sorry the two that are home and play soccer yeah at different
times in their soccer careers were offered to play in a higher soccer team and we're like no oh why why
because they were too nervous oh really so it's catching so i gave them my fucking anxiety
anxiety does ding dong david come along with some really helpful fathering advice to these to these young
nervous you know anxiety riddled kids yes i feel like you don't you know you're
doesn't help. No. It's a good balance. We love David. We do love David. Just because he's not in front
of the camera for my sister, Tracy, David created Game of Thrones, your husband. Yeah.
Are your sisters with, sorry, I don't understand the conceit.
My sister. Every once in a while, we have to remind the audience. Good, thank you, Will.
It's helpful. But wait, Amanda, did you, when you were growing up, oh, go ahead.
No, you go. No, Willie, go. No, no, go. You guys are so polite to each other.
Wait, Amanda, when you grew up with a mom in that field, did she kind of try to psychoanalyze you all the time?
Like, did you have somebody to talk to?
Was it therapy constantly in the house?
You know what I mean?
Okay.
To be honest, I was, yeah, I was very, very close with her and very, very similar.
And was sent to the therapist right when I came out of her vagina.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
I was like, talk therapy.
Let's go.
You came out with the car keys.
You're like ready to go.
Did you ever feel like you were getting a free analysis from her?
Or was it like, I can't really share with her my feelings because she's just going to psychoanalyze me?
I think that she...
Like was it a plus or a minus?
Okay.
My sister would disagree.
For me, it was a plus.
I didn't feel like she was looking at me as like a test dummy.
for her psychological theories.
And she was even in psychoanalytic training in the 90s
when I was in college.
And I thought it was really intellectually interesting
what she was talking about and really, really helpful.
And I think because she felt like her mom was a clinical narcissist,
she was hell-bent on being a good listener
and seeing my sister and me for who we were.
That's how I feel.
I think my sister felt a little bit more
like there was this like
psychobabble orthodoxy.
That's older sibling.
Oh, yeah, my older sister.
Did you think about, did you think about
through that process?
Did you think, oh, maybe this is an area
that I want to go into?
Did you consider doing that yourself?
Well, I always think acting is a little bit of that area.
Sorry, that question was for Amanda.
Sorry.
No, Sean, go.
I, yeah.
No, no, no.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I think,
when I look back, I was in, this is very unusual,
I was in psychoanalysis at age 13.
So I went to the shrink four days a week.
Wow.
Talk about, you know, first world problems.
And I think the idea of psychoanalysis
that there are these inciting incidents
that set you on a path on a trajectory.
And that's storytelling.
You're basically creating a narrative.
I mean, old school shrinks,
which they are not creating it.
But I think it's very similar to storytelling in every way.
And then we create, and then that, create that narrative,
and those sort of neural pathways get deeper and deeper and deeper those grooves.
And if you're, the danger is that if you don't do that,
I'm not advocating either way or whatever, I don't have really a position,
but that if you, that those things get so deep that that becomes your,
story entrenched in your mind about who you are i am this this is the way and you can that can often
lead to i think as you get older you know you i know i know i speak for myself the story that i've been
telling myself about who i am for the longest time is become this thing that i've i'm like now at
this age almost 56 and going like wait i got to i got to look at that because i've been i've had this
narrative and i'm not a reliable narrator on this and you know truly yeah nor is ever
Any 13-year-old, by the way.
And so it's blame, there's a lot of blame, right?
When that idea that there is an inciting incident that something happened to you,
it takes away what it doesn't count is style of thinking.
How you, you know, it's nature and nurture.
How were you born?
I was born with a much more anxious mindset than my sister.
And I think the idea that in your childhood,
this A, B, and C happened, it can involve a lot of blame.
And so I think it's maybe for some people harder to take accountability.
I don't know if that's that sort of what you're saying, Will, like you're sort of like...
Yeah, I think so.
I just think that we all have, first of all, we, everybody has their own sort of chemical makeup.
And so you can have two people, like you were saying, you and your sister, you can have two people who grew up in the same environment with the same parents, the same thing.
They're completely different.
We see it in our own kids.
I certainly see it in mine, and they react differently to stuff.
And then, and it's true in my experience that I've grown up and I do things differently.
And I'm only now at this age, started to go like, wait a second, all the stuff that I thought, like, I didn't do that early on.
I didn't go to psychoanalysis when I was young.
Thank God.
Well, maybe, but also now I got to sort of retroactively, like I'm much more actively really searching to try to unlock a lot.
lot of the stuff that made me who I am today good and bad in trying to understand it a little bit
and go like, why do I do that?
Why do I make the same mistakes?
Why do I do this stuff?
Good man.
Yeah, it's better to be self-aware enough to want to figure it out than just float along.
Right.
And maybe you just wouldn't have had the emotional intelligence that you have now to really do a lot of deep
and honest analysis and introspection.
You know, so it's, you know, good time.
You're ready when you're ready.
Yeah.
We'll be right back.
And now back to the show.
Well, Amanda, speaking on, keeping it deep and heavy now.
Oh, shit, sorry, God.
No.
What about when you're-
What about when you're playing parts and stuff like that?
Are you enjoying and exploring and utilizing all the different parts of you
and injecting them into these characters?
I am so fucking into acting right now.
Or do you like playing completely different people?
Oh, I'll do anything.
I like both.
Right, but I mean, what is, what is, what's like your, what's like your strategy?
Like, are you, are you, do you think about, okay, how do I create an entirely different person or, okay, I recognize a part of myself in this character?
And so let's explore that part of myself and we'll just call her whatever this character.
characters called?
Well, I'm mostly given parts right now at this moment that are more, probably more like me.
And yes, sometimes when right before I do a take, if I catch myself thinking about how to,
trying to be good.
Right.
If I think, like, I'm trying, if I.
Is that similar to, is that similar to try to be good or thinking about how to play it?
Yes, like orchestrating anything.
Orchestrating a result.
Yes.
Right.
I try to pretend that David or Sarah Paulson are there at the video village.
They'll call bullshit.
And that they'll call bullshit.
So I say, okay, now you have to do one where they have to,
they're going to have to guess whether it's real or not real.
Whether it's really you or not really you.
That's awesome.
And that's the strategy for this moment.
Yeah, because a lot of actors...
work so hard to let you know they're not acting that it looks like acting.
Oh, you're right?
Yeah.
Whereas if you focus on just like performing for one microscopic lens that, for some
people, it's themselves, right?
Like, for me, it's that case.
Like, I know I'm going to watch my performance here and I'm not going to be able to
get away with anything.
You know, I'm not going to give myself any sort of, you know, relief.
Like, it's got to be super, you know, like, I'm watching.
For you, that microscope is David and Sarah.
It's never Amanda.
Huh?
It's never my best friend, Amanda?
No, I can trick Amanda.
I can trick her.
Stop it.
No, you can't.
No, I can't.
The other Amanda, sorry, just to be clear,
the other Amanda.
Oh, sorry, I'm very close with J.B.'s wife, Amanda.
Can we talk to the other Amanda?
Amanda Panda.
No, Amanda and Jason were in what movie together?
There were two, right?
Was it just two or was it more?
Oh, God, oh my God, I forgot about the...
I forgot about the person.
I mean, she came out of the gate with Sauty,
and she forgot about your shit.
Yeah, thanks.
Which one did you forget about?
Which one did you pour cement over?
I forgot about the wheelchair one.
Do you don't remember the title?
Oh, I know that one.
We'll wait.
Oh, my God.
In fact, I think it was...
I remember that one, too.
Yeah, what was it originally called?
With Armistens in that, too, right?
Is that the one in Charles,
Groton?
I couldn't act with him because he was too funny.
It was released as the X.
Oh, that's right.
But what was it called originally?
I think it had a better name originally.
What was the director's name?
Jesse Peretz?
Yeah, Jesse Peretz.
Look at me.
I can't believe you know that.
Look at you.
I know.
Well, Amy was in it, right?
Amy was in it, yeah.
Sean, you didn't see it?
I had time I, I took my cue.
I played an asshole in a wheelchair.
And Amanda and I play...
A week away from that.
We play...
We play ex-boyfriend, girlfriend, or kind of I wanted you to be my girlfriend back in the day.
But now we meet up later in life.
And we were on cheer team together when I wanted you to be my girlfriend.
Oh, my God.
Sean laughs.
Yeah.
Wow, Sean.
And there's a moment in the film where I'm in my wheelchair and we see each other.
And I go, hey, do you?
Hey.
And I say, hey, remember the move?
and I lift you up over my head with one arm as a seat.
You're sitting on my hand up over my head as I'm sitting in the chair.
Did we, we did that for real, didn't we?
Or were you on cables?
I feel like we may have done it for real.
Cables, why?
Because your hand, your arm is so fine.
I mean, I've seen your nearly atrophied arms.
I don't think that's pathetic.
Yeah, I couldn't do that with my children.
But I feel like we may have...
No, we rehearsed over and over again.
We did that for real, didn't we?
Yeah, we did.
You mean there weren't a couple grips wearing green suits holding her?
Nowadays, they'd have to.
But it was...
That was very fun.
Yeah, Charles Groden.
I love Charles Groen.
And then we did Identity Thief.
Yes.
Remember that one?
I sure do.
The thing I remember about that the most is Amanda breastfeeding MAPs in the hotel.
Yes.
That's what I remember.
Jason's Amanda.
Again, it says a lot about your acting, Jamie.
That's what she remembers.
That's a great, that was a great movie.
I love that identity thing.
Yeah, it's a great movie.
So much fun on that.
Ms. McCarthy crushing it.
All right.
Let's get back to the beginning.
Let's roll through this a little bit.
We're going to pick up the pace here.
We're doing so much time bullshit.
You grew up in New York City.
You were born in New York,
grew up in New York, right?
Went to school in New York.
Born raised.
Where did you grow up in the city?
In Manhattan?
In Manhattan, yeah.
Oh, we're 11th and 5th.
Oh, look at that.
What is the most New York thing
that is still a part of your everyday behavior?
Oh, that's a good question.
What do you think you, because you lived there for a while?
I'm working here.
Right.
Yeah.
What would be the thing that that city gifted you in your persona?
Psychoanalysis, of course.
Yeah, yeah.
Everybody's looking inside over there.
Bagels.
Yeah, when you leave New York City, what do you miss the most?
Just the whole McGillicuddy, the subway, the rubbing shoulders with other people.
Yeah.
Where are you right now?
That was by mistake
I mentioned
Oh God
I'm in the bedroom
I mean are you in New York
or Los Angeles
Oh sorry
Jesus I'm in Los Angeles
Yeah we live in Los Angeles now
Yeah yeah yeah yeah
All right so you're starting out
JBA are we on a snack break
I'm sorry
That's the last fight
I thought I moved the microphone
Far enough away
I apologize
What is happening
So you grew up in New York
And you say to your
And your parents are a million miles from showbiz, and you go, hey, I think I'm going to be an actor.
Now, were you doing any sort of like jobs before you got started that maybe you could say, well, but I'm, this is kind of taken off for me and I won't have to be doing X anymore.
No, I was doing school plays.
I did all the school plays.
And because I went to a tiny Quaker school,
I was, you know, one of the best singers there,
which is saying nothing.
Right.
And it was a short order, not a tall order.
And then as soon as I got to college,
I started, I sort of walked in confidently to all these auditions,
and I never got a single play.
I auditioned for 20 plays, yeah.
Oh, wow.
Really?
It was as if they had already decided
they already had their own click.
Yeah, they were like, no, no, these parts are reserved for people who were good.
Were you not studying drama?
Did you...
I took a teenage acting class that my mom found for me starting when I was 13, too,
as well as being in psychoanalysis.
No, but what about college?
Where was that? Where was that? Where was that acting school?
Where was 13?
That was at HB Studios.
So eventually my teacher...
HB Studios!
Yes.
What's the half?
Yeah, as a lot of actors get there started.
Eventually, my teacher said, you know, you really need to study with Uta Hagen.
And so my junior year at college, I auditioned for Uta Hagen.
Now, what about in, so in college, were you studying drama?
No, I was studying American history.
Yeah.
So never went into the drama program.
Because I bet if you joined the drama program, they might have felt obligated to put you in a play.
There wasn't a drama program.
What's happening, Sean?
That's Scotty.
Oh, that's Scotty.
He's just striking the set.
He's just striking.
Yeah, I said we're just striking the set.
All right, so then you start auditioning.
Well, okay, so college starts to beat you up a little bit
and tax your confidence.
Meanwhile, you're like, I audition for 20 plays.
I'm not getting anything.
This is for me.
Like, what's the, what's the thing?
Did you go out and get an agent?
How did you start auditioning?
I hadn't really admitted it quite yet.
I still think, and I had, it's almost like, you know,
what people say like, you know, like a self-hating Jew or something like that.
I was like a self-hating actor.
I couldn't quite admit that I wanted to actually do this as more than a hobby.
And was it the same for you, Sean?
Oh, no, I'm just enraptu.
Oh, I thought you were like, yes, I relate to that.
Yeah, no, I'm just like, yeah.
Oh, no, Sean was a prodigy.
No, no, I mean a little bit, yeah.
Well, you know, when you're young, you never think you're good, you know?
Like you're just like hanging on by a thread.
I mean,
I've never been more confident than when I was young.
And then I go old enough to realize,
oh no, Jason, you're full of shit.
But also because you worked all the time.
Like I had this similar.
I moved to New York and I didn't get anything for years.
Like, why the fuck did I keep doing it?
Yeah.
Nobody wanted to hire me for anything.
But Amanda, you went out,
but Amanda at some point you went out and got an agent, right?
And you started auditioning?
Yeah. So then once I was in Uta's class,
I was in an adult class at age.
18 and so people had
headshots and agents and they taught
me what the
backstage magazine but also
the Ross reports where you could look up
there was a little booklet and it had every agent in New York
City and I just would start crossing them out
and I would take the subway and go to make a day
make submissions and I would go in person
with like full makeup
yeah you had to want it right and
and slip my headshot under the same
and they'd be like thank you
We got it.
Stop pushing it under the door.
Stop pushing it.
Yeah, we don't take unsolicited headshots.
You know what?
I've never told anybody this story.
This is absolutely true when I was like 23.
And I had like a headshot.
It was just terrible.
And like nothing of fake resume.
Did you look worse than you look now?
Can you put your hands for your hair please?
Sorry.
Fix it.
It's off your forehair.
There you go.
It's cute.
Pethead.
And I went up to 30 Rock.
This is before the advent of like high security.
and stuff.
And I went to 30 Rock.
And I went, it might have been even 92.
And I went in and I got on the elevator and I went up and I put my resume on the desk at 8H.
At SNL?
At SNL.
Honey, not everybody knows what fucking 8H is.
I'm sorry.
To be a spoken by Studio 60.
I actually didn't know that.
And have they called?
So you thought you were funny.
I don't know.
I mean, you're right.
But I just...
But talk about confident and unwarranted.
So you wanted to be on SNL early.
I thought about it, but I had no...
I didn't do sketch or anything.
Anyway, this interview was not about me.
But I did go and do that same thing.
I went and I put the thing on, embarrassingly enough.
I just had this image of me sliding my...
Just like you said, Amanda,
sliding my headshot and resume underneath the door,
waiting three seconds, and it just comes right back.
With a bunch of piss on it.
No, just a big sharpie on it.
the outside of the envelope.
And you guys,
you guys, not only that,
but eventually,
so I auditioned for agents,
you know, like I did monologues
in their offices,
and eventually I got repped,
and the teen rep
walked me to the corner
of 57th and 7th
with one of her colleagues
and said,
and she was saying,
congratulations, we want to rep you,
and was sort of giving me
the lay of the land,
and then was like,
um,
and the other thing,
we just wanted to know,
so for your,
you have a little bit of, you got a mustache a little bit here.
We're just wondering what can we do about that.
Oh my God.
What?
Oh, my God.
Was she right?
She was right.
Really?
Oh, my God.
Wait a second.
So how old are you?
Don't name her, but what agency?
What agency was that?
It was S-T-E at the time.
It became paradigm.
How old?
Right.
18.
19.
You were 18.
And you had a little bit of a fuzz there.
And, and.
Wow.
I think it must have been more than a fuzz
because I've seen a fuzz.
Okay.
What was the strategy on removal?
Was it bleaching or waxing?
She's like, no, watch this.
I'm going to grow it out.
Take that.
What was this?
What was this strategy?
Jamie wants to get it.
No, I want an answer to that.
Did we bleach it or did we wax it?
We did everything.
We did nearing.
We did bleach.
We did fucking, you fucking name it.
Yeah.
Wow.
Isn't that something?
I would pay so much money to see my face and see myself try to handle that.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
And be like, oh, yeah, yeah.
Was that so.
I had an agent recommended nutritionist to me once.
Oh.
Yeah.
And I was like, this was last week?
Got it.
About 18 months ago.
I know the guys of it.
It did a lot for me and I was like, cool.
Hey, I had a really big.
big shot agent not too long ago pitch to another person that I work with say, hey, if it's ever
appropriate and you feel like you can kind of squeeze it into the conversation, ask Jason if he'd
ever consider highlights.
If he had highlights, it would really open things up for sort of like real sexy kind of
leading man.
And I was like, motherfucker.
Are you serious?
Did you do it?
Studio exact.
No, no, agent.
King, King agent.
And did you do it or no?
No, I did not, Shawnee.
I have not colored my hair since the incredible Frank Stallone vehicle Philly Boy on CBS in 1990.
You have so few grays, too.
You have so few grays.
It's so.
They're coming.
I do feel like they're coming.
There are a few that are trying to fight their way.
Okay, so wait.
Now, so you get this note about.
the stash, you're addressing it,
are you feeling like, yes, this is great, this is a good
thing, or wait a second, is that what this
business is going to be? My feelings are hurt.
I'm not getting a lot of stuff, even though I
just got a new, I should quit.
Did you ever feel like quitting at any moment
in your career?
I think more later,
I think it was more
later. I think that...
Because the opportunities weren't what they were
what you wanted or it was just like, oh,
I'm good. I have nothing left to prove to myself.
I've had incredible success and
next.
It sure wasn't that, Jason.
Well, it could be.
I've had an incredible success.
I'm going to go rest on my laurels now.
I completed everything.
Take another look.
Yeah, I think, well, you know, like once I started writing a little bit,
and when I was shooting the chair, which, you know, when I was behind the camera and all
the ladies, like Sandra O and everyone had to get there earlier, and I could roll in in my
snow pants with my mustache and my hair and just be and but still be the boss i was like this is
fucking great what have i been doing this whole time right and then yeah that's okay so then that so then
the latter and it's really fun to have you know to have last cut final cut right well let's let's let's
let's talk about that let's talk about how did how did the chair come into your orbit so so so folks she was
the creator, the writer, the showrunner
for the Netflix series
called The Chair, starring Sandra O.
And so was this,
how did it come to you? Tell us about that.
Because I went to friends
in Manhattan on 16th Street
and there was a teacher who was there
when I was there, who was really lovely.
And in the New York Times,
it was in the New York Times,
there was a huge Michigas
because he was in a math class
and he was pointing
to something and he was,
He made a Nazi salute joke.
Who's he?
It was the teacher.
And it became at Friends Seminary at my Quaker school, this huge controversy.
Friends is a school.
Manhattan Friends is a Quaker school.
And it was the beginning of...
It's a joke. You broke. Your love life's D-O-A.
O-A. Yeah.
You know.
I can't believe they still go there.
All those six friends.
Jen's going to figure it out.
Sorry. Go ahead.
I like this idea of having a woman of color
who was the boss of a white dude who transgresses.
And it was sort of the beginning of cancel culture
and all that stuff.
And I knew this teacher to be a lovely, kind,
Quaker-leaning human being.
And the fact that he's incited this whole controversy,
I thought this is such a good story.
What, can I ask, what's a Quaker?
I mean, I know what a Quaker is.
I know what Quaker oats are.
Yeah, that's all I know.
But what's a Quaker school?
What does it mean?
You know, it's a Christian denomination, but I feel like they're the greatest.
They really take the word literally.
So, you know, there's no priesthood.
You know, in a Quaker meeting house, anyone is allowed, regardless of your religion.
There's no priesthood because the idea is nobody is closer to God than anybody else.
Oh, got it.
It's called a popcorn meeting when someone stands up and speaks because anyone...
Also great fiber.
You want to talk about a denomination that's got colon health?
You need to go no further.
Oh, was I getting boring?
Was I getting like...
Yeah, that's our job.
We got to pop it in every once in a while.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, but tell me what...
Poop farts.
Mustaches.
You got to do it.
We're just dumb dudes.
Hey, what about...
What made you think that you could be the boss?
Nothing.
Yeah.
The writer.
Nothing.
Yeah.
What made you think?
But everyone would love to like
Would like to have their own show on Netflix
I mean like how great
Well first of all I watched David and Dan do it
Yeah and you're like
These two guys can yeah
Yeah
Holy shit
Exactly
No I was like oh my god I better not fuck this up
I think it's just like love of actors
That was it
That was like my starting point
Scary though right
Clearly immense writing talent
and we're going to get into that.
But like, where did the writing talent come from?
You didn't study it in school.
I did.
You did?
Okay.
Yeah.
American history and American culture.
Well, I just took a lot of creative writing classes.
Okay.
And then acting just sort of took over,
but I was always kind of dabbling.
And then I think when I married David,
he was really encouraging.
When Studio 60 got canceled,
he was like, take a step.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Especially you, and that was.
Aaron Sorkin, wasn't it?
So you had, you had, you'd just been under that.
I mean, my God, those, yeah, those scripts.
Incredible.
So wait, all right, while we're on the writing thing,
let's talk about this incredible essay
that was just published by the New Yorker
a couple of weeks ago.
If you haven't read it or looked for it, do so.
It is, I mean, you tell me, Amanda,
is this not the equivalent of, of an,
Oscar for an actor to be a writer and to get published in the New Yorker is the zenith of accomplishments.
I lost my mind.
I can't wait to read this.
What's the name of the article?
It doesn't have a name.
It's...
But what would you name it?
No, I mean, like, how do I find it?
Just Amanda Pete New Yorker?
Yeah.
Oh, there's a start.
Have you ever used the internet?
Sorry, I should say.
I have read it and it is, not only is it an incredible piece of writing, but the subject matter, it is, it is nonfiction.
It is, it is about our guest and her family and mortality.
And tell them the rest of it if you're comfortable because it is just stunning.
And it left me with real wet cheeks at the end.
Thank you, J.B.
And I mean facial cheeks.
Sorry, I need to be clear.
Will, where is your thing or d'ar?
I know it's so far away.
You missed it.
Hang on a second.
Jason, just say facial cheeks.
And I had, and I ended with real wet cheeks afterwards.
Facial cheeks.
The boys will put that together.
I don't believe that actually work.
And we will be right back.
And now back to the show.
Amanda, tell us about some of the things that are revealed in this.
I mean, deeply, deeply personal.
Well, so on the Friday of Labor Day weekend, this last Labor Day weekend,
I went to my breast surgeon.
I have what's known as dense and busy breasts.
Guys, I'm not going to hit that softball.
You all leave that to you guys.
Keep your finger-dinger near by.
I feel like you were looking at my search history.
Okay.
You really teed that up.
No, you guys, for real, it's a real thing.
And it means you have to get tested all the time.
Do you mind telling me what, because I'm super into medical stuff.
Like, what is that condition?
What is, if you don't mind?
I guess it just means that you're, it means that on,
screens, it's hard to detect cancer.
Okay.
Because it's, I guess it's a little bit like a forest or something.
I don't know.
But there's like too many, it's too dense and busy.
Like vascular and cardiovascular kind of things.
Yeah.
But all jokes aside, that's scary.
That's scary.
Yeah.
So I was used to going, I go all the time.
I go every six months.
I get ultrasounds and as well as mammograms.
And so she found something on the Friday of Labor Day weekend.
And right before I left, she said, I said to her,
do you think if you were a betting woman, what would you say?
And she said, I think it's cancer.
Oh, my God.
So I went home.
You had to wait for the results for the test.
Yes.
So then she said she was going to walk it over to Cedars because it was a holiday weekend.
I was like, I talk about Xanax.
So I came home and then the next day,
David went down to San Diego
while we were waiting to hear from the doctor
because the kids had a soccer tournament
and my sister called and told me that my dad was about to die.
So I flew to New York and
and my poor sister
had just dropped her last kid off at college
and...
So she's in a great mood.
So she was dealing with a lot of closure and loss
and so my dad passed away and...
I'm so sorry.
Thank you.
Yeah.
The essay is really, really funny.
It actually is.
This is what, this is, this is her, her superpower.
It is, it has the most devastating things in it and the most hilarious stuff in the middle.
It's really something to work to read.
I can't wait to read it.
So anyway, when I got on the plane to come back to L.A.
To get ready to get all the tests and go through the whole process of having breast cancer,
I was like, surely I can.
right about this. Surely this is a weekend from hell that there's got to, it's got to be.
But you're not thinking New Yorker. You're thinking just sort of a cathartic kind of let me just
journal. Yeah, I wasn't thinking that far ahead. I was just like, this can't be that common.
I mean, not that like I, you know, I mean. The weekend from hell. Yeah, the weekend from hell was
sort of what I was thinking. Yeah. And we, meanwhile, my mom was also in hospice. So both my parents
were in hospice at the exact same time.
Jesus Christ.
You know, I just...
It's all this past year.
Just now.
Six months.
Yeah, just now. Yeah, six months.
And I was very lucky.
Everything's, you know, I'm clear.
I did radiation.
I have extremely lucky the cancer they found.
It was cancer.
It was cancer, yeah, yeah.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't know.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
So I was, like I said, like very, very lucky.
No one knew this, right?
I mean, it is in the article is your first mentioned,
the first time you've gone public with this?
Yes?
Yeah, I think because, you know, we didn't tell the kids right away because, you know, Frankie,
we dropped Frankie off at college the week before.
So we, and as some people know this, but cancer, most types of cancer, it takes a while
to find out where you are.
Like, what is your treatability?
What kind of breast cancer do you have?
How big is your tumor?
And that tells you how to treat it.
Yeah.
But, and, you know, I found out later, now I know so much more about breast cancer.
and other cancers too.
I mean, there are types of pediatric leukemia
where you don't find out for a year
whether you have a treatable course.
But the waiting is insane making.
It's just insane making.
So, yeah, we didn't want to tell the kids for a while
until we knew whether I was going to do chemo
and what the course of treatment was going to be.
So I wanted to keep it a secret
because I wasn't even telling my children.
Wow. Wow.
And then your dad passed while you were waiting for the...
While he was on the plane, yeah.
While you were in the plane there.
Yeah.
But you got there in time to say goodbye.
Yes.
Yeah, it's all in the article.
Jason.
The essay, it's like it's so well written.
So wait.
So then now you're,
now you get home, you're starting your treatments, your, your mom, you're being a saint,
she's living with you in hospice. Yeah, Jason, Jason has come and seen my mom many times. So she,
yeah, she was single. My parents got divorced and she was single and living in New York. And so
she has Parkinson's disease. So once she was wheelchair-bound, we, David being, all jokes aside,
the mensch to end all menches, moved my mom here. And we took her.
So she was living here for the last seven years.
I mean, your stuff that you write about, your connections with her right there at the end,
or just everything.
That's so beautiful.
I had no idea all these years that your mom was living with you.
You never talked about it in any way.
And you're like managing this, you know, vibrant career that is after all these years,
even more vibrant and...
Writing and doing stuff and you're shooting that show.
in New York, right? You're shooting your show with Ham
in New York at the same time.
Shooting with Ham, yeah. They were really
lovely, like last summer, before
I found out, I had breast cancer
Tropper
and John Hamm were very beautiful about
my mom being in hospice
and letting me go back and forth all the
time. Like, I have very
special bosses, I have to say.
Well, this is really amazing
because every time,
I didn't know any of this was going on.
So, every time
see you, I always laugh.
I was such a great time with you.
Same here. And you're always so
positive and have so much light
about you and around you. It's
a Zanax, you guys.
It's not down or dripping. No, it's like
you're always laughing. Well, there's Ritalin.
She does a sidecar of Ritalin
as well.
Sidecar.
Sidecar, riddleon.
It's true, though.
I really want a sidecar of Ritalin.
She is the light.
She is sunshine.
You're such a, you're such a
joy.
Like, it's just amazing that
to know what just goes to show.
You have no idea what anybody's going through.
Right.
Yeah.
I think my mom, thank you, first of all.
But, yeah, my mom is that way.
Like, a very Jewish sense of humor.
Like, very, we're asking about what I miss about New York.
Like, she has that very New York-y,
neurotic Jew, sharp, witty sense of humor.
And throughout her Parkinson's, you know,
I mean it's an horrible disease
I know you guys probably know a little bit about it
and she never really lost her sense of humor
that's amazing never never so I have a good model for
as Carrie Fisher said always look for the humor
yeah yeah for sure
all right so we're going to take a look at that essay for sure
are we going to a clip or
For the,
Yeah, it did sound like you were about to go to a clip.
For the folks who don't know how to read
and just enjoy their dose of Amanda Pete
on the screen,
they've been enjoying your friends and neighbors
quite a lot.
Yeah.
As I would imagine.
As I did.
You are too, Amanda,
notwithstanding the hours spent with John Hamm.
Because that can be,
tough.
You know, this guy...
That would be trying.
He's a nightmare.
Let's face it.
Yeah.
Well, you know, maybe this is...
People will catch on.
People catch on and we'll finally be rid of them.
But until then, you guys are great on this show.
The second season is coming up here in the spring, as well as your new film.
Let's talk about your new film.
It's called Fantasy Life.
released March 27th.
You are a producer.
You are a producer on that and also
the co-star
and you were awarded, what were you awarded for that?
Hold on, I don't want you to have to say it's yourself here.
I believe it was some sort of special award
at South by Southwest.
The film won the audience award as well.
I mean, this is, and I saw it the other night
and it's effing great.
It's a real naturalistic, you know, let's put it this way.
If you loved Will Arnett's film, and I know all of our listeners did, you will love this film too.
It's got a lot of the same really great naturalistic sort of texture to it, if you will.
No one's swinging for the fences with some like, watch my performance crap.
It's really effortless quality.
When does it come out, Amanda?
I was swinging for the fences.
With a literal bat.
You never ask the audience to watch your performance.
You're never screaming.
Like, hey, look at me, act.
It's so easy to watch you.
I'm screaming deep inside.
Look at me.
Whatever it is, it's working.
Was that a great sense of accomplishment?
Because you've been doing great work on,
this is what, your first film in 10 years.
Was that important for you?
Is that true?
People keep saying.
saying that, can I just say something?
It's not like I chose to not work in a movie for 10 years.
I just couldn't get arrested.
Yeah, but you're no longer, you know, pushing your headshots under doors and stuff.
I mean, as you said, you've got this healthy, sexy, indifference guys.
Yeah.
And you're busy doing things that are a little bit more important to you, I would imagine.
Yes?
Honestly, it's really just what is the writing good?
And in this particular case, this indie writer came to me with this idea of, this was before baby girl, it's basically like a sort of upper crust mom who has...
This is Matthew Shear?
The upper crust mom, yeah.
Yes, but Matthew Shear, it's like she has an affair with the manny, basically.
She has a character you play.
Yes.
And when I read the script on about page 15,
this neurotic, speaking of neurotic Jews from New York,
he has a scene with his shrink where he's talking about his OCD with Judd Hirsch,
and he's having these self-hating Jew intrusive thoughts
where he sees like a Jewish guy on the subway with a big nose like David,
and he says, hook knows, hook knows, hook knows.
And he thinks he's going to say it out.
loud and I was like well this is brilliant I want to do this.
Oh wow.
It's just so fucking funny.
It's really a lot funnier than how I'm pitching it right now.
No, it is it's but again it's not asking for laughs.
It's really tasteful.
Alessandro Naval is in it with you as well.
How funny is he?
Yeah, he's great.
Wait, when does it come out?
March 27th.
Which I believe has already passed.
We're doing this a little bit ahead of time.
But yeah, we are...
No, I know that, obviously.
It's in theaters now.
Go out there and grab it, y'all.
Now, what is my next question?
Here I come.
I'm coming down to the page here.
I know.
Jamie, just go off script a little bit.
Just, you know, what do you do for fun?
Well, you know what she does for fun.
Yeah.
Dents and busy.
Oh, no, that's what Will does for fun.
Wait, Amanda, what does the rest of the day look like today?
No, that's a great question.
question. Yeah, let's do that one.
This is the most hard-hitting journalism.
No, you're not.
Are you out of your mind?
I'm really boring.
No, I want to know. I want to know because I want to, first of all, I didn't know anything
that you've gone through in this past six months or year.
And now I want to know, like, what do you do all day?
Because the kids are away, right?
What do you do all day?
Like, because, you're about to start, are you about to start press for, for both the
film and the show?
Yes.
And is that something that you like?
Do you like going out there and doing all the chat and giggles?
What do you guys think?
I feel like when you're proud of it.
It all depends on sleep.
If I slept, I'm great.
I'm going to do anything.
I'm tired.
I don't want to do it.
Do you have trouble sleeping?
Let's talk about sleep because...
Yeah.
I think as you get older and smarter and the brain works better,
and there's more stuff to think about,
sleeping gets harder.
Yes.
And I just read somewhere that it used to be...
By red, you mean TikTok.
Uh-huh.
It's on TikTok.
By the way, it's true.
I think I did see it on TikTok.
Where the, where you sleep.
It used to be hundreds of years ago,
people only slept for three or four hours, got up,
and then there was a second sleep.
Yeah.
Says who.
TikTok.
That is true.
Yeah.
He's right.
And then so that's kind of what happens to me.
I sleep for a little bit.
There was a time in New York you can look it up
where people used to go and they'd walk around
in the middle of the night.
It would be, I remember reading this, there was a book about it, about these,
and people would walk around sort of at like 1 a.m.
And there'd be like a kind of a nightlife that people,
sort of before the advent of widespread.
They've got to get your eight hours.
Electric bulbs and all that kind of.
And that people would go to sleep earlier.
And then often wake up in the night and they would have like a reprieve from their sleeping.
I am definitely looking that up.
Go for you.
Are you guys, are you ruminators when you wake up?
How do you keep your brain from being like, death?
We're all going to die.
Catastrophic thinking.
Do you have catastrophic thinking?
Yeah.
You do?
I mean, I've been, yeah.
But so how do you stop yourself, Sean, when you,
so you have two sections of sleep with a thing in the middle?
So what, are you able to put your phone away?
No, no, I play games or I'll read or do whatever on my computer.
You know, like I'll look, read, I'll read stuff that I find interesting.
But most of the time I'll play games.
But doesn't the blue light?
Didn't people tell you not to put the blue?
I have glasses that's soft in the blue light.
So that's a great look.
You've got the glasses on, the CPAP, and the,
and then you got the, what's it called, the Beetlejuice?
What's the, what's the game you play?
Candy cry.
Candy crush.
That's hot.
But it's more about what that's doing,
sort of firing all those things in your brain instead of,
In that moment, if you were to wake up and pick up a book,
you might find it easier to get into sleep.
Will is constantly pushing reading on this podcast.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Mostly about World War II, though.
Not recently.
No?
World War I now?
Or are we into Vietnam?
Which direction are you going?
The last, you know what?
The last couple weeks, I've been into more sort of modern noir.
Okay.
And I did one of those things, right?
I said, what are the best modern noir books of the last 10 years?
What would you say?
What do you say?
Yeah.
And they sent me a list of books and I...
You know Noir?
And I just read about it.
Uh-huh.
Oh, sorry, Sean.
Hang on.
Sorry, Sean.
A little late.
Little late on the draw there.
Wait, is that fiction or nonfiction?
Fission.
It's been like sort of like crime and, yeah, yeah, yeah, it's been interesting.
I know it's so good that you read all that well.
That's so good.
Do you read a lot, Amanda?
I try.
Yeah, I try to read a lot.
I, um...
David reads a lot.
David and I've exchanged books.
I know.
We've handed each other books before.
And now he's listening to The Rest is History.
Do you know that podcast?
Yes.
He's obsessed.
Yeah, it's very good.
It's really fun.
What is it?
Like an audio book or something?
It's a podcast.
And they talk about history, but in a very accessible,
hilarious.
For dumb dumps like me?
For dumbdums like me.
Yeah, like I'm doing the one on Iran right now.
Oh, wow.
And they're so, they're, Will, don't you think they're so funny?
Very, very interesting.
Not as funny as you guys, but they're funny.
But where do people have the time to listen to podcasts?
On the finger dinger.
Where are you getting in the car?
No, I'm watching news when I'm on the thing.
But J.B., if you look about it, look at it this way.
You dedicate, I'd say 80% of your time that you watch TV, which is about 80% of your day, is you're watching news.
The other 20 you're watching sports.
I keep waiting for him to get caught, you know.
No, no, no.
My point is, if you were to delegate some of that,
time to listen to sitting in a chair in a room with headphones on staring at the wall while you're on the
exercise machine or i do it in the car will in the car yeah in the car and listen to these guys i think
you'd find it pretty interesting but i can't finish it my car rides are like 15 20 minutes is that
okay and you just pop in pop in pop out yeah you'd pick i do that with them especially if you're
interested in one section will it hold my place i don't want to have to start over when i get back
I just take a screenshot of where I am,
and that's how I know how many minutes have gone by,
and then I return to it.
Of course you do.
You can probably do it in an easier way.
I love that you do that.
Boy, that says everything.
Really?
Yeah, that taught me a lot in a great way.
I'm scared.
No, no, no, no.
It's very methodical, and I really appreciate that.
Well, she's a Capricorn.
I'm a Capricorn.
You know, we think shit through.
Fuck that.
I need to give a shout out to Amanda Anka and say that I'm a Capricorn, yeah.
Yeah.
What are you guys, Sean?
She knows you're rising and you're whatever.
No, she still needs more information, apparently, to tell me exactly what I am.
I am cancer.
How about that?
Oh, wow.
In every situation.
Yeah.
I'm like a modern-day Fred Nord.
I'm like a low-rate Fred Nordstrom-Hauer, yeah.
Wait, Sean, what's your rising?
I don't know what that means.
Okay, me neither.
Will, what about you?
Sean, you don't have a joke for what's rising?
and Sean?
Taurus.
Bois,
Will,
you know what your rising is?
I forget,
but Amanda,
Amanda Ake does that.
She's got it all on us.
She's got a full forecast for all of us.
So she could, yeah.
She could tell us what's what
in the coming.
You're right.
I had to send Amanda,
Anka
like a year ago or whatever,
like what time.
I had to ask my mom
exactly what time
day I was born.
I did all this stuff.
She needed to have all this information.
She wanted to know
if you were a good match for her or not.
She already knew.
Yet she's sticking with me.
I love her so much.
She better.
And you don't want to know who else I love so much?
Who?
The other Amanda in my life.
Amanda Pete, today's guest.
And we want to thank you for your hour and eight minutes.
We love you.
We certainly do.
I love you.
I love all three of you so much.
We love you so much, too.
We love your husband, your three kids, the whole thing.
I love you.
And your talent.
So go out there, read that essay in The New Yorker, watch your movie fantasy life,
watch your show, your friends and neighbors, and stay tuned for the next half of this incredible
woman's career and life.
Oh, my God, I'm going to start crying.
I'm going to cry.
I know how you.
That was so nice.
We love you.
We do love you.
I do love you the best.
Thank you so much.
I love you, gentlemen, so much.
I'm going to hug you so hard when I see you.
Is that a bit of a sense?
I promise us.
Squeeze me.
Okay.
Love you.
All right.
Bye.
Love you guys.
I love you too.
Bye.
That was Amanda Pete.
One of my dearest, longest friends.
I know.
One of my all-time faves.
Same.
Super funny.
Yeah.
And like I said, she's always so bright.
No one would ever know anything's going on ever.
No.
She's always.
Not that that like, you know, it's just somebody who knows how to.
I know.
Always walk in a room and light it up.
Yeah, for sure.
screen too like i just she's just always sort of ground stuff that i watch um and uh always kind of
elevates it kind of smarts it up you know what j b i have a recollection of before you guys were friends
before you'd work together that you always admire you used to talk about her in this way that she was for you
like kind of the gold standard and she was like one of those people you wanted to work with her really
yeah yeah you know you know in the best way yeah yeah yeah and tayleone was like that for me too yeah
and still to this day like i just think there's there's a julia
Roberts is like that too.
There's a strength and a style of humor and also of drama that, I don't know,
that all kind of remind me of each other.
But yeah.
She is a treasure.
And, Sean, right about now is when you start to say, hey, guys, have you ever...
I'm looking.
Do you remember the time that I...
Do you remember?
Hey, guys, you want to know what my favorite film of hers was?
And then he kind of works it in that way.
I'm coming.
Oh, God, wait.
We're going to cut out this pause and wait.
Oh, are we?
Yeah.
You know, that David Benioff, husband or hers, you know,
they've got kind of like a dual,
it's a double-barrel shotgun over there of talent
and accomplishments.
And they're sort of...
You know.
Yeah.
Sorry.
And...
You know.
You know, yeah.
I thought that would be a great tea up there for one of you guys.
I know.
Wait, yes.
Oh, God, we've got a caller.
A caller is, uh, oh, you know, one of my favorite jobs that I've ever done.
And Amanda P happened to be in it.
We talked about it earlier.
Um, a real treat.
Yeah.
My friend, my favorite, Amanda P.
played my wife in, by identity thief.
That was pretty good.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav and Bennett Barbico.
Smartless.